catchup 103 come round so fast you think
would have caught up by now when you I
went to America twice as far as I went
you were on a podcast with the AMA I
shared some oxygen with Ilan Mahoney
wrecking it absolutely destroying you do
listeners have tuned in you do you just
it's so silly things is our only purpose
on the podcast so just derailed nothing
interesting to say you know it is as
well
like people can say that they think that
Americans are too positive or like over
the top which is probably probably a
little bit fair but in my experience
Americans are so much more polite than
the Brits the whole Marvel [ __ ] and this
is going to offend on people by really
never all the earth will be and have you
seen any of them yeah which ones there's
a guy with a big glove big bloke big
gloves gonna make this little [ __ ]
gems you have to put in the glove when
you put some into James nickel oh yeah
he kills those people sorry stop the
podcast we need to hold here they want
ladies and gentlemen welcome back and
joined by Joni and Yousef from propane
fitness comm catch up 103 come round so
fast you think would have caught up by
now on you whether the problem is that
we're a conveyor belt of catching out
where things constantly happen do we
need to catch exactly faster than we can
actually get them out but the map is not
the territory because if we were
catching up at the exact pace that they
were coming in we would just be live
broadcasting all of our lives we should
be current yeah we would we would be
streamers and we're constantly behind as
well we would be streamers I have a
microphone in on my desk and these kids
will pass the other day actually what I
do a webinars
they're very similar Rezanov webinar but
they're crucially different do you need
your ad set optimizing they give the
appearance of live a lie yeah webinar
webinar and so yeah it's been not that
long since the last one but loads of
stuff happened so we're gonna catch the
[ __ ] or catch all of it up catch it up
into one big bit have you got a synopsis
of what's happened over the last so two
months ago Johnny doesn't drink eggs
anymore
doesn't drink eggs anymore got injured
Johnny got injured you've been a hermit
I did I did get injured yeah you doing
Crossfit yeah you now exhaust it well as
of tomorrow I mean when this goes live
anything might fund yeah what I love is
that you're what what constant you
thought you were doing Crossfit like you
you did it CrossFit does that mean
you're not doing crossfit what's your
current training methodologies yearning
great good eyes all right now CrossFit
say it well no because I haven't done a
CrossFit yet directories fit but I have
to do the CrossFit like three hour this
is how to CrossFit yep you do anyway
moving on I feel like we would you
parley Johnny with questions though okay
what was the name of the first female
president what's your favorite color
don't know somebody named a person who's
been
a favorite cup of dog green okay green
dog right so um why have you done Yussef
I've literally just been medicine yeah
deep in the hole the vilest new weeks
now so what are the final few weeks of
doing a medical degree like for anyone
who's considering doing it so your your
anal tone is non-existent
when you say anal tone yeah can you
describe really you that you can't
maintain the integrity of your so you
think you're continent buzzes normally
but instead it's just yeah my farts
don't make it sound like a windsock yeah
I'm saying that as an analogy for the
intense fear that I experience day to
day so this time last year I had a heart
rate monitor and my resting heart rate
was between eighty and a hundred it was
happening all the time with everything's
watch yeah Nakia definitely didn't give
that away from an influencer program for
free sorry Withings so what's the fear
the fear is comprised of having to reset
the year yeah it's this the ninth ground
it's the night bro is that you yeah so
what if someone gave you nine grand now
and said if you have to resit the will
pay it didn't want to use the night gram
for something else but you can't do that
I think the NHS pay for one reset so
what you're bothered about it is a year
of my life
so you bother mother 9 grand are you
bothered about the year of your life
it's the whole package
laughs so there's two scenarios one you
can Rhys it and you can do it
immediately but it's not grand the other
don't do that you paid 9 grand right now
again rather than it's pre you have to
do it this way max yeah I mean eight
that's like nine grand or a year of your
life
yeah because easy trick is you've got
opportunity cost lost earnings potential
compounding of that lost earnings time
for the following years
yeah easily now that slight when you
spent nine hundred quid on a little bit
for your car and you said to me that
you'll never get that no no no quick
buck and you'll always be no worse off
it's like that but with 9 grand
yeah I went to America twice twice went
to America to debark and then you gone
don't come back to it yeah Kim came back
again yeah
like it was not a short gap between two
e trips so our shuttle run two weeks
what stops you just staying that do you
think I do out of beat well yeah and a
life don't draw see you CrossFit
prostate to do mr. cross so ya know what
first trip was really cool flew out to
Redlands to go into film with Rawat
again got to see Daniel and Sean are the
two people that all known Daniel showed
me his fancy new 911 Turbo which is
terrifying very simple is it supper yes
very yet its best it's lost its er
there's a terrible reference to if
anyone knows in the comments what 911
it's the best yeah this isn't a joke
based on 911 you know right where I find
cuz you're an Arab yeah God we need to
be careful those races rounds it's a
clip from The Dictator okay you're still
waiting to see it yeah maybe just give
me away that's true
[ __ ] it see you Ron what do you do
differently wrong with this time than
last time
so very similar sort of day in terms of
filming
they both times actually I did some of
their yoga workouts before hunt so the
guys that honor Ahmad have a huge yoga
studio attached to the side of them and
video Gardein should be throwing clips
in just as we speak and they're going to
be going yeah exactly just whizzing past
but the problem is we don't know we
don't know when we're going to be held
in that YouTube loading bay you know
where it's just us and all of the other
youtubers that are doing cutaways
waiting to come back we don't know when
that's gonna happen
I said why just can it be dropped in
purgatory do you understand
took me a while I'm with a cast or for
the wrong word I mean I suppose we had
so many perpetrating ones we are anyway
so one of the one of the big differences
was I did a bunch of yoga workout before
hunt a lot of silicon in in American
yoga studios a lot of silicon hold on so
yoga workout distinct from a normal
Rawat workout
yes so robots like just yin yoga they
have a huge yoga studio that has a
thousand members are like 500 members or
something next door to where we film is
that Brandon Rawat know so it's the yoga
rooms in Redlands highly recommend
anyone who's listening from Radler so
the owners of rawat yep have a separate
business yes which is the first business
which is a yoga studio which has classes
which regularly top 100 people and that
has a lot of silica in it there's a lot
of enhanced women there right
ah I see so you live sinking silicon
floors wheels like so there's the like
that's the primary that primary market
appears to be in the heavy amount with
no other not big boobs not necessarily
before they go and so women maybe 30 to
50 55 very well presented fair bit of
money Redlands quite quite a sort of
affluent area and there's just there's a
lot of chests like high volume of chests
and I asked I was like why is s at 12:05
3-1 maybe um I said why why is there so
many big big boobs here and it turns out
that like a couple of the members their
husbands are cosmetic surgeons they just
business that's it yeah it's just what I
was the big pyramid scheme
yeah that's all it is there's a guy I
follow on snapchat called the Miami
doctor don't know if you've seen him
he's a plastic surgeon in America that
just documents all of his like bum jobs
and boob jobs and everything and thank
you he is just I he must be raking in
now she's got such a big exposure and
just live streaming his surgeries really
live streaming cutting someone who's not
mine
brutal is what I think it gets their
concern and like he does like it before
and after so he brings the camera over
to their pre picture and then goes over
to the like freshly sewn up person but
the trunk is like big metal tumor that
he's just good enough because it's
reciting ever seen anyone have
liposuction ya know like a scrape in it
like wow big like a sword yeah that's
the sort of thing that used to sharpen
knives with Jesus Christ do you know
yeah I thought it would be more like
more akin to like just whipped cream I
thought we'd just fall out in there mmm
you've got to like to touch it from the
well that's painful so yeah um did these
yoga workout avoided getting too
distracted by all the for silicon they
were really [ __ ] hard there's one of
them where they add a load of weight to
it so there's a weighted bar that you
have like a workout bar probably about 3
feet long a good barbell no it's not
it's it's it's it has the appearance has
the appearance of a barbell but it's
only 3 feet long and made of rubber so I
guess there's the hell silicon a heavy
weight and what might be silicon
probably everything in there is [ __ ]
silicon actually so that happened I feel
like we all just give a derailer
[Music]
wrecking it absolutely destroying you
okay so your listeners have tuned in you
didn't you just it's so silly things is
our only purpose on the podcast so just
derailed nothing interesting to say
that's so yogurt barbell weighted just
it was really difficult one thing mark
one thing that um Daniel sloth said when
I was speaking to him was he said that
Americans tend to make like a woo noise
from the back of the room
and I was like in yoga no that's
generally when he was doing his sets and
he's like general enthusiasm so it yeah
its enthusiasm it's just what he knows
whoo
it's just off-putting right like he
doesn't like the fact that they do it
and he complains at them and he tells
them off and he's like look every time
you do that I'm gonna stop really it's
very gods with a Scottish
yeah you've been behind it for yet
bloomin so
he says that he's gonna stop and I was
laughing about the fact that they do
this cuz it's like Ric Flair right I'm a
Ric Flair the wrestler anyway that was a
perfect opportunity to derail the pond
because that's nobody missed it
so I'm in this yoga class
he's already warned me about this wooing
thing that Americans do and as it
started to build up in the intensity of
this yoga workouts getting more and more
people start booing from the back of the
class and they're like come on you've
got this you can you can stay like if
you do it like a hollow hold or like it
like an ab crunch or whatever and you're
holding it for a little while and
there's people from the back of the
class that wooing what I noticed was
OU's a lot of the people who had dropped
the hold and it's like look if you've
said hold the bottom of an air squat and
everyone's in the bottom of an air squat
and you're stood up and you're going woo
mmm that seems unfair taking a piss
don't pretend to be a part of the people
that are grinding it out it's not very
like deeper joy breaths as it's done by
the yoga so it's very very untraditional
they mix music live like they've got DJ
decks that they mix music live and loop
the music as they build up the intensity
incredibly well done like super super
welder best anyone who manages to like
emancipate that to the UK is fly so I
love the difference of movement so I've
been back at yoga again the last few
weeks and it's like you're afraid to
even breathe too loudly on you and not
in that one that we go to very
traditional but there's no like no no so
it's a loud loud club style music this
type playing Queen this type playing
country it's like very rocky very very
hot and sweaty and this rooms massive
Tina make it appear but this room is
huge and they've got as you walk in
there's Lululemon like the biggest racks
of Lululemon you've ever seen and a huge
open desk with juices and smoothies and
everything's expensive and really nice
and then they're just huge huge studio
where people are like mats are side to
side to side it was just it was
impressive to see what happens when you
take a concept and
like high amount of experience and then
kind of flip it on its head a little bit
it's still yoga but really no one no one
could probably recognize that so yet did
that film for romnod like for no six
routine today including two warriors
some of which has got seem worries in
the day to worry has put one more eight
of each day but like five or six of the
routines pretty hefty including some new
poses which are terrible and incorporate
walls so you imagine that you've got a
wall in front of you and you're putting
your arms up on the wall but you're laid
flat so it's like a seal pose but
instead of arms pushing onto the floor
or on the wall so you're falling through
your arms
actually I cannae kept us there for ages
I did it him his wife and me were Cole
modelling what was going on yeah if
there was one if there's one way to make
your wife like being a mood with you
it's write that pose and then push her
into doing the routine right so that was
pretty a lot of your inflection spinal
flexion the whole time and opening up
the shoulders as he can fall your head
through so that was fun and then ya went
to went to LA and spent a fair bit time
on Venice Beach in Santa Monica and was
just reintroduced to this electric
scooter phenomenon which is completely
destroying LA in a cool way but it's
just the maddest thing to see now
there's for people who don't know bird
lime I think it's like up and something
else our runs of scooped nominees who
have just dropped these 24 kilometer
Electric mini scooters like what you see
kids riding around on school children
but they've got a little trigger on them
which when you push it accelerates up to
about 16 miles an hour and a little
break and everyone is just whizzing
around on these scooters and you open it
like a one of those ride on bikes that
you can get in the UK that's like a
micro scooter with an electric motor is
it because the time is so fast that you
need it's because a lot of people
already skate and buy
and there's heavily pedestrianised areas
that are built fit of I guess riding
areas they're built for exactly that
what's the problem with normal bicycles
the the not as cool okay and they don't
go as fast and I can let youth really
owning it you have to use it so every
different iteration of scooter and
electric vehicle has now been used by
these people so you've got like an
electric scooter one then you've got a
bike one where you can both pedal and
use the electric motor to go even faster
and they're [ __ ] rapid and there's a
skateboard one now where you just escape
board with a remote control
and you scan it and you can just deposit
them wherever you stop and so it's
exactly like the bikes yes okay you know
much better much better faster more like
cheaper as well $2.00 to start and like
I think it's like 15 cent a minute it's
like 10 P a minute to write however far
you want it suppose you're using power
on you yeah and then there's a you have
to dock in certain snow so this is an
entire sub market of charges so people
get paid to charge these things you sign
up as a charger take the things home
with you plug them into your wall and
then you get money based on how many you
charge I'm so looking forward to this
like decentralization at you so with the
Tesla thing as well they're saying you
can if you get a Tesla that has the full
self-driving unit you can then uber it
out to people when you're not using it
so it can take you to work and then you
just leave it to just taxi people or is
that really what this says internal
facing camera if someone likes spunks or
vomits a new car and then you can always
clean that up off of what vmd was just
like trying to yeah or both and then you
can just charge them for it so just
automatically as well so could just make
you money while you feel like there's a
gap Burt because that I mean they
already exist don't they Tesla's can
already drive themselves but it's best
be safe enough he can just yeah did we
talk about this last time where we were
saying how people would rather die
own volition yeah that their own folly
then die from and what a mated car even
though that the chance of dying is like
a thousand times less yeah it's like
just people don't like putting their
life in the hands of something but they
would much much sooner make Leone make
their own era wouldn't they would you if
you offered to have if you had to have
surgery for something and you were
offered to have it done by a robotic
algorithm that's got that like micro
things would you do I'd want to see what
this success rate okay assuming it had a
much higher success rate yes fine
would you I'd want to know how many
operations the algorithm okay so you're
not the pilot facial voice I think that
the algorithms gonna learn based up so
the surgeon let's say us tend to ten
thousand hours of experience the
algorithm may have only seen what's been
programmed but like it's how the surgeon
react based on the experience in a
nitrogen excellent answer that is it
once I'm gonna win the Jetix I can't get
out of my mind
this the new Pirates of the Caribbean
movie which is just come on Netflix is
[ __ ] [ __ ] not seen it Captain Jack
Sparrow steals a safe which attaches
itself to an entire house or Bank and
then they have like four horses that
ever you can imagine all these horses
I've got ropes behind them they've
attached it into this safe they pull the
safe and it's this comedy thing where
they've hooked it through the back of
the building
and the safe is gonna pop through the
back of the building but they don't they
just dragged the whole building for like
two towns the entire buildings being
pulled behind all of these horses in the
Sun Wow yeah and it's just that's
ridiculous and Johnny Depp has
completely lost his mind to sharing
around like well it's ji min comes over
this is the worst thing is that I don't
think that he even knows who he is when
he takes off the Captain Jack Sparrow
thing now it's been shaving his head and
wearing like t-shirts was smuggle the
dog into Australia or something did he
do you see that no news it was always a
while ago I am sure him and his wife if
he has a wife so out of touch I am with
us yeah he was on the news do you know
what it is D dinkum big hands me
Dean is shaking his head at me [ __ ]
speak he did something where he was
having to publicly apologize for
smuggling another dog into the country
Jesus Christ that's right why I never
started my public apology Australia
well that sounds right nice baby it's so
weird that just because you're a
celebrity is really nice to them do
public apology for taking a dog that's
true yes what's this reason why do I
have to project my apology as a Jack
Sparrow
yes captain judges this is yours the
thing we talked about on catch up
whatever one yeah one yeah that is
bizarre isn't it like once you're in the
public eye anything that you do is now
[Laughter]
surely taking a dog across like nice I'm
only between you the dog and border
control the dog is culpable you're
facilitating those crime yeah maybe I'll
say it might I mean the dog my
threatened him I just got poseable films
come I can threaten that husband yeah I
also didn't like age of Ultron from the
Avengers that the whole Marvel [ __ ] and
this is going to offend a lot of people
by Rhian a girl with her phobia be seen
any of them yeah which one's the one
where there's a guy with a big glove and
he's got iron fist
like big fist big bloke big bluff like
this little [ __ ] gem that he has to
put in the glove and when he put some
into James nickel oh yeah
he kills those people this is the one I
watched as he has there's a really sort
of lovely justification for it but and
then people with hammers and he's a
bloke with a hammer he tries to stop him
Commerce this one yeah we were closer
she will he tries to stop him again
doesn't manage it guy with the [ __ ]
gems in his glove that's got a chin big
shame a bit like a scrotum doesn't huge
big kid looks a lot like a scrotum so I
know what this one is
it's just
bragnae Thea what's that that can you
not go profile for this and then
retrognathia is the other observer to a
life are rather yeah I think I'd rather
well what if one of our new friends
right but friend of the show who will be
listening Alex Lonsdale had that way at
the underbite two surgeries pretty man
when he had that when he had that so yet
you have you just right hook yeah do you
actually can you explain what the
procedure is so the the jaw is just set
anteriorly to our should be so the the
joint is there from this forward so they
have to just break the whole thing so
they break the how do they break the
things that i don't know how they must I
don't just pop off I imagine you don't
you know okay my god when I had a kid it
like you can't change the hair yeah by
pulling all the head or the hands
conscious and you can pull it the hard
time Kenny oh yeah it's just like a
stake at the end well it's just that
isn't it we're here in lego man you have
a square head with a hole in top their
hands like that only thing that would be
good for feet with holes and only thing
that having Lego hands would be good for
giving [ __ ] and eating Subway
sandwiches kipping pull-ups or
interacting with other Lego on fat gripz
because all legs straight combined like
a Lego hello yeah hello how are you
you'd have to do this wouldn't you hello
you stay still well if you're set unti
really good what is it yeah pop pop top
so that snap it shape some of it off
possibly I haven't haven't seen the
procedure but like and then you have to
stick if I kid what causes that is it
muscular or is it things the way the
bone is set must be structural custom
structural ostrich but calm down making
you all go bug someone I met said that
she had a tight jaw TMJ and she met
someone who is MJ
temporomandibular dysfunction AMD the md
j joule jump today and massage therapist
told her is because her pelvic floor was
tight so here we go release this is this
is just were venturing into the world of
chiropractors now everyone's been to a
physio what what the problem is
clamshells made by show love if anyone
could let us know in the comments if
you're a physio or if you know physios
why sun physios so fatty because you get
the physio that just loves
kinesio tape and just piss on everything
regardless of what the SIBO tape Sabina
Christy Oh God and then like expound
walks or single leg glute bridge you get
my personal trainers doing the same
thing to me like just give everyone like
you've got that ability window all old
middle-aged old woman who's very
overweight and just gives it like twenty
ones for curls connection right so back
to America these scooters like the best
wait one of the problems is this is the
only thing I didn't get footage of of me
riding around Santa Monica and Venice
Beach on a scooter but it was anyone
who's considering going to LA the best
way that I've found so far to spend an
afternoon is rent one of these scooters
and right from Venice Beach to Santa
Monica
she's a maybe about a one hour journey
on this scooter you got past big
basketball courts huge skatepark so you
just stop off grab an ice cream like
unbelieva this amazing scenery loads of
cool kind of crazy people they're
playing music and and just selling
street art it's just sick like sounds
love [ __ ] awesome awesome experience
and get range anxiety no cuz you can see
on your own yeah so give you a warning
before you yeah okay so you don't have
to go back okay and even if you did even
if you took it all the way today you
just get off going out of the one other
one there's the number of things that
you see on the app as well is unreal
like you're never more than 100 hundred
yards from one of these things and in
some places where they know that there's
hopes of people about to get to the
beach 20 lining the sidewalk and they're
all different brands so it's like all
you get are you looking for a birdie you
looking for a line are you looking for a
like oh like whichever one it is do you
think it'll come to you k so one of the
problems they're coming up against at
the moment especially in San Francisco
so the way that they do this is buy a
bunch of them
set the app up cordon off the
pedestrianised areas so that when you
ride into them it just kills another
thing and you have to walk it out right
and then just deposit them in the city
but obviously because there's so many
companies doing this now I think I sent
you guys the valuations of it like in
November last year and it went from half
half a billion to one billion to six
billion to eight billion month one month
one month it's like four months now how
the [ __ ] is the valuation of this stock
gone up so much where everyone's getting
into it so San Francisco said that
they're not actually going to allow any
more than I think two or three companies
to operate at once and they're going to
have it unlike a rotating scheme in them
whoever operates the best will they'll
be allowed to stay Wow
but yeah I think it should come to the
UK one of the problems is obviously we
don't have tremendously good weather so
the demand for it's not going to be that
good it rains seven days of the year in
LA so there's always going to be but as
the rain seven days of the week in the
UK yeah exactly I did one in Berlin but
what it wasn't a little scooter is like
a proper like electric bike electric
yeah yep basically they go fast they do
use it's a full like it's equivalent
like a rubbish motorbike but it's like
my pepper electric yeah and like if
there's a helmet on the back and
albert is like a box that has just a
bunch of disposable hair nets and so
they're very European hygiene a year
that's different the way is in America
like in America everyone's just like
boom and everything yeah yeah so that
but glass a unbelievable way to spend an
afternoon when swimming in Santa Monica
College outdoor pool that was pretty
sick went to Disneyland no I'm not
there's an answer Universal Studios
which is just like big kids dream no the
right Simpsons land Harry Potter world
is just like such a Simpsons land
well that experiential stuff like it
just brings out the big kid in you so
much like if you're walking around and
when went and paid $14 for a Duff Beer
in Moe's Tavern because it's [ __ ]
most haven't I think it's it is nice
that you can appreciate that because I
feel like I've become such a curmudgeon
Arthur
did it curmudgeon like a just grumpy old
man right if I went to like Simpsons
used to do I challenge anyone to go to
Universal Studios Hollywood and not just
have the mouth open the whole time like
it's just so [ __ ] cool you walk into
Harry Potter world
you walk down Diagon Alley and there's
like none to be pointed platform 9 and
3/4 and the trains sticking out and then
they do live musicals where they've got
magical frogs and like it's just unreal
like everything about it it's sick and
is this a man's job to be the magical
frog no so the magical frogs like a hand
puppet that sing I've got five single so
it's someone's hands John's pan chopped
it's a hand job ok you get you have ever
pounced on me put it in the Frog I don't
think that hand jobs are the best as a
job as a job she only has one these are
the hands-free ok so you can shake hands
the people are not yeah
at the same time yeah but I just think
things in America everything in America
is done properly isn't it
so I'm gonna there's no half measures in
America it's like to the max you notice
as well like people can say that they
think that Americans are too positive or
like over-the-top which is probably
probably a little bit fair but in my
experience Americans are so much more
polite than the Brits
an perfect example of it I got a number
of examples of this but the best example
I have was walking back from an evening
meal coming back into the Airbnb or a
state walking downstairs and walked
through the car park downstairs like
sliding gate car park thing which you
can imagine you'd then follow up a
stairwell to get into the actual
apartment block so I'm pulling through
like 11 o'clock at night pretty dark by
this point and a huge Lincoln Navigator
thing like a teen seat car massive
blacked-out windows black brand-new
shiniest [ __ ] comes through and in it is
just streams roaming the weeds illegal
in LA as well so too everywhere streams
of like marijuana smoke just pouring out
the sides of this this guy is just
pulling out of the gate that's slowly
opening any like front wheels go over
the top of this thing from backwards go
over the top this little thing look in
and it's a group of black guys like
maybe five five black guys all with
hoodies on hoods up like that
rap music coming out the side of this
car marijuana smoke pouring out and I'm
like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like this is I
mean a downstairs carpark of this thing
I mean a country that I don't know it's
not near that the guy who's driving
who's obviously just bleep the bleep the
thing turned around
bleep the gate again so opens and goes
good evening sir it drives out I'm like
even even the [ __ ] thugs here even
the people that are like terrifyingly
scary a super polite hmm are so funny I
think when people stereotype Americans
they forget that it's better because
always Brits that do it you think like
what's the spectrum of British people
that you've got that was you and then
you've got like the all the way to
wealth people Scottish people yeah so
actually we've got this huge range of
people super dynamic right so then say
that Americans are all one thing when
the country's so long
probably even the more diversity between
I've been west or whatever over the last
few weeks I've been red ones in LA so
inland from California and out on the
most Boston which is northeast and New
York plus I've done a number of other
places in America previously everywhere
that I go the service staff is super
polite like even people who say to the
service did he tip that you have to do
you know about how much service get paid
in America hardly anything is in there
it's like the only people I think the
only people who don't have a minimum
wage they say well it's two dollars an
hour and some places they literally work
like for tips it's like straight out
traders get paid a basic income it's the
same philosophy like they get a 10 based
on the performance earning yeah I think
they often get paid quite a lot I think
you were in the right place well I mean
based on how many how much the tipping
like advices you're talking up to 20
percent of the bill like for a for a big
table but I'm unsure like even if you
give a bad service you still like it's
still a faux pas to not tip isn't it
they just say on my Hans not to I just
leave them a smaller that's what I don't
like about it is like there it's it's
fixed the half the tip so then it's not
tipping it's not performance-based
because yeah even if you were to guilt
noticed yeah yeah like if someone's done
a good job and they get a bonus fighting
that makes sense but if it's just you
have to take its cutter from a business
perspective because what they're doing
is not doesn't have create a culture of
not having to pay your staff which yeah
do you tip in the UK I tend to usually
up to a probably about 50 quid table
round up to the nearest five or ten then
over that tend to go about 10 percent is
that only for food or if you tip her
they does tip it drinks like oh I just
tip in a restaurant normally if like
it's been a good service being a good
experience one bad thing but I don't
know I'm not really a fan of it I prefer
to pay I make more because like I think
I don't want to have to make the
decision because I am i under tipping
what yeah
the company just like paid the
statically yeah results I'd I'd rather
pay higher prices and for typically just
be eradicated hmm it's much simpler ten
percent I think in the UK seems pretty
but it's weird isn't it the tipping
stopped at restaurants so why like you
don't in a salaried employee you don't
get tipped why not the tip [ __ ]
everything so tipping the bellboys in a
hotel yeah and stuff like that I'm like
but it makes you realize you could just
be doing folk paths everywhere and not
realize because it's just not nice I'm
ordering a drink in America and it was
expensive it was like twenty dollars for
a single drink and the woman said back
to me that not be the right money and
and she was then this sort of back and
forth with me in her I was like what do
you mean is it better not be the right
money like it's the correct money just
right for it and then the guy was with
David I gave her extra money and she
calmed down but so then but there's no
sign saying I make sure you tip that you
know see if you're new to it then you
just sit so you're asking what how do
you define a tip or they say oh it's an
optional payment based on good sir
good then actually if they just get
hungry when you don't it's not really
optional it's like if I'm you're on
twisted and it's a weird one
so yeah did that then went to Boston
vast vast right it's great it's the best
American Arctic you know it's sick so I
spend a bit of time with Kerry from
inside track issues that the lady I was
dealing with from that lovely people
that flew me out there and if you're
glad to dad today that I've had my blood
stamp which will be on the Napa so did
Chevron's already heard every bit every
bit of it
what are they measure and what were the
results well it doesn't exist yet so
it's up its up next week but last like
two weeks ago in podcast line all right
place pockets landed its I love being
here it's great
hello is it nothing's happened yet for
time and space don't exist um but it was
fun and carries the first person who's
got like born and bred near Boston and
just has the accent is such such a
fantastic I feel like you're in like a
Martin Scorsese film yeah very much so
like Mark Wahlberg like but really broad
she's just taking simple alike even Mark
Wahlberg is is in the Boston accent
isn't it just saying the name
Mac way back so yeah that was fun Boston
psych on a lot of war it reminds me
quite a bit mucus I wouldn't know what
about your Bloods mine what do you all
know what happened what so I was but you
could have met it once you just burst
think they know like what you see
reactive protein is and you're not
telling so they took they took ten vials
of blood I got a question dices
took quest Diagnostics in California
took my blood they're after fast for 12
hours beforehand then they sent the
blood off to Boston ahead of me and had
it tested ready for my arrival I had the
tests done I am does everybody else have
to do this like travel around this is so
usually just have your results sent to
you but I want to see them ahead office
okay you were discussing it with David
Sinclair David Sinclair yes like the
hyperlipidemia Caen HBA yes and I could
we saw was a little bit a little bit
high on lipids a little bit high on
glucose free test is a bit low
understandable overtraining
what cortisol test ratio is fine which
is good I need to eat more soluble fiber
so I saw this on your Instagram remember
yeah Nate Wiggins need to muscle just 20
different types of beans beans beans
baked beans and he was like
of which leads you may have noticed the
little koala which is attached
microphone the listeners are you're just
going you're just going to have to
imagine what it looks like it's a little
koala holding I think a Boomer Allah and
um we need to come up with a name for
him so if you'd care to submit a name
for the koala chlamydia chlamydia koala
you know I don't think that's going to
work yes lock the midian what don't get
to Coney with a quarter they've all got
chlamydia sorry stop the podcast we need
to hold here they want so koalas have a
really high concentration
lots of it yeah so how do they get it
from each other yeah where did it start
I imagine wait how much that's a
complicated question
I've always wondered are like who had
the first sexually transmitted infection
because I was thinking the other day did
dogs have sto nice butt and if not why
not and if so why cuz like you must have
this this prime jogger who just has
managed to box everyone like literally
[ __ ] because there was BST I'll just
never get any traction because whoever
had it in the first place just doesn't
get to go again ever yeah that wasn't
cool this the starting activation energy
the initial desert there's a scene on
the thick of it where someone is insult
to somebody else is you're like the man
who [ __ ] the monkey that gave us a yes
is it Malcolm Tucker's insulted someone
else so yeah koalas let's not call it
commit a koala but that's okay I can't
believe they have chlamydia it's such a
lovely little cuddly thing I know you
want a hug look oh this doesn't have
chlamydia
hopefully it doesn't I'm just checking
that I've come correct it's useless
serious onslaught the sock Arthur is not
the same one that in facts are humans
thank God but they will have it with a
wall of chlamydia because they're all
just in big [ __ ] sex party what's
this
top question can you catch chlamydia
from quarter what's this that is koala
koala here chlamydia
it's also Cavalia
koala Kawakawa so you can get blindness
infertility and dirty tail the Koala
dirty test so you get to tell you what
to see am an Australian man I assume
yeah so the David Sinclair thing was
weird man
so he um I sent him an unsolicited his
email as I do he replied and said yes
are you from Newcastle Australia
I said haha no Newcastle UK turned out
that I was already going to Boston to
see inside tractor I said am i all right
to come and see you at the same time is
a assistant agreed and then went to go
see him so good he had someone big in AI
in before me and I said is Elon Musk and
he didn't say no so as far as far as I
went you were on a podcast with you um I
shared some oxygen with you on my own
yeah exactly
so you have too much glucose bit too
much fat on a fiber and not enough
testosterone you kind of essentially and
you to what you're in you're in a bit
too old for you right no so to not tell
me a length test which I'd love to get
done at telomere length would you care
to explain what telomeres are foods yes
sir so there's a and bit two part of
your DNA structure the high but how long
it is is one of the biggest correlates
with how long you're going to live
assuming you're not hit by a bus or
something okay and meditation and yoga
extended like Tai Chi particularly like
stops telomerase which is the enzyme
cuts it away from ya so well there is a
that an actual life lengthening think of
it and I think kids who have had kids
who have been exposed to violence at
young age have shorter telomeres so that
is a very accurate way of looking at
your inner age but what inside track to
do is they aggregate all of your markers
a and you can imagine that would be the
same as whoops
recovering perhaps where Hydra gets a
bunch of different markers and gives you
an a single output
Johnny's away from anybody's away from
we've now
it's not that they read everything so
the reason I'm over aged with regards to
that is that my glucose there's a lot of
weight towards glucose which is easy
enough for me to bring down
well [ __ ] is really addictive isn't it
anyone who has a high carb diet those is
a difficult difficult why I'm joking
so David Sinclair yeah like the guy has
an australian knighthood like the
equivalent of a knighthood put the
australian one where you don't change
you're not chained you title you don't
get Ohio you're a knight nothing well
that's the whole point of a knight here
does he get well that's right so he's
hoping a Jedi Knight the British okay so
he um he had that and I actually used
the little metal thing to prop my phone
up to record a podcast walls just filled
with awards this guy's like he knows
like a machine from he's a monster
Murray I could yeah he says add the
Aging's in like like the life extension
longevity live but he is he bridges the
gap between academics and business so he
doesn't just discover things for the
purpose of discovering them he tries to
bring them to market which is a date
like he's Tony Stark
he's literally Tony Stark when he comes
that yet unbelievable man and he was
saying that for about four weeks a
couple of times a year him and his wife
become millionaires and then because
he'll come up with some new discovery
have a patent for it I have the
discovery trademark and then once he
gets the money in build a company spend
all of the money starting the company
and then just go again and if it's
reliable like if he's doing it over and
over again then she lands on me
well he's not what he's gone this is
conscious if he's constantly becoming a
millionaire it'll be a time when it
comes many as oh I'm sure that there is
I think he said this is the reason that
my wife bites her nails because he just
constantly plays around rocking the bank
account would be like yeah
opened down there I think the I hear
constantly that like the the
self-tracking wearables world like
that's where there's going to be the
most jumping and advancement you know I
before were me long before there's an
implant that you were the met that
monitors your markers I think creeps me
out
I hope [ __ ] habit exact like when
happens in a pitch is you're a Charlie
Nylund
yeah actually would give me grass sleep
day yeah Charlie I see pay for that
there's a guy who did a really haunting
video about the was it called 23andme
and there's a stuff saying that you only
need a certain critical mass of people
to to do it then you control these
inferences and you can use it for
forensic things so if someone's commit
so let's compare to crime you can then
find who it is through like three levels
of facts of relationship and so like
they were saying how they basically the
some intelligence agency found who
committed this crime
just from googling DNA data choosers and
finding like three people who it could
be and then speak to their family and
this is one of the problems I suppose
that everyone house with this constant
surveillance thing it's that the price
that you pay for more data that you can
use is more data that can be used
against you mmm-hmm yeah nothing to hide
is a fantastic way to feel about your
data being collected until you have
something to hide I think it's just the
it's looking at the motive so it's the
means and the motive isn't it so like
someone has Facebook have your data like
yeah they can use it against you but
like why were they worth of yeah well
it's not they wouldn't but it's more
like what are they stand to get out of
it yeah and yeah you might become a
person of great political influence or
whatever but I just think on balance
it's unlikely so and why why do you
think Zuckerberg has tape over his
camera
I didn't know he did so you know when he
was in the court case like there was a
shot of him on his MacBook yes it was
cool yeah taped over isn't like I see
when you see something like that I found
that quite worried you should put tape
everything I mean the main thing but the
main thing for me is that Steve Jobs
inventor of the iPod didn't lie his kids
play like birds yeah that's another
Islam is that Thursday the reasons or
was that because he doesn't like the
idea of the it's because they're
addictive and you know horrible pieces
of technology that you destroy people's
ability to focus
that's wise yeah yeah it's a tough one
isn't it there's that they've tapped
into like a deep just a way that we work
they live lay it something on to us the
reverse engineered it yeah do you ever
think you who would you be without
screens if if no one ever showed you it
I don't think about it now like I think
because the world is so linked to
screens it probably quite difficult to
live without a screen yeah you probably
don't know but what in a different
iteration of the world at weather
weren't screens in the world iPhones
what sort of a person and personality
would you be what would your resting
thought processes deny what would you
pretty much karma I think GDP will be
low yeah I think the output of the world
would be much less harder to communicate
as everyone just delivered really good
services because they're all like doing
Superfortress books and training in that
yeah well but it'd be harder to get
those services to people yeah but then
you know Amazon for example which have a
blurred with by cream yeah you have to
write a letter
thumbs requester excuse me can use your
drove we do that [ __ ] hell I was I
was reading Morse code I was reading
about Amazon's future logistics plans if
you read this with the drones yeah so
with drums and but more so with just
traditional
postal service at the moment right so
just buying up fleets of plane like Jeff
Bezos is buying up fleets of planes and
they were comparing them and is it the
American Postal Service are they the big
ones
mmm I think the American Postal Service
have got nearly a thousand planes and
have 63 but there just was growing them
yeah just consuming you seen the clip of
the drones being dropped out the back of
an Amazon plane and then going to go and
deliver parcels yeah so that's another
thing you've you seen you you've all
seen the video of like the mock
slaughter BOTS yeah yeah we've talked
about that a few times that please
they're pretty scary
the there's a really interesting podcast
nevah no it's called masters of scale
yeah a guy who's realized yeah he
interviews the the founder or the first
guy that like made a DIY drone so I took
the military technology and just to talk
about turning like his kids Lego plane
into a drone and gets it a fly itself
and he's like he's playing with his kids
in the playground and he gets this plane
like for a few moments to fly itself and
his kids are like bored now and he's
just like standing in this park they
just got [ __ ] hey what have I just
done
oh I'm sure like the software so
duplicatable yeah and you can 3d print
the like that's why it's such an
inflection point because we could just
push baby podcasters talks about how
that's such this like when you think
about it it is a tiny little robot that
can fly in the air and like real hard it
should hop yeah really hard to stop like
look what happened yet was it Glasgow
and no Gatwick no we're done we're like
[ __ ] shut the airport that's some
bloke with a with a drone motor control
you really long but she lives drone like
even if they say all will just put a
thing in the stocking above a certain
height like easily someone can go on cos
my passion just like yep so Navarre rava
[ __ ] did a podcast on what's called
after on Rob reads
podcast and this is basically end games
how we can how we can die so a lot of it
there's a lot of stuff to do with drones
very super intelligence II a little bit
super intelligence II but their main
thing is this sin bio synthetic biology
that they're going that and the problem
is that with Crispin now people can
recreate
plagues and
h1n1 and h3n2 at age three and three is
that [ __ ] podcast isn't it
h1n1 yeah so they can create these but
much more scalable yeah I phone up
that's really popular where you create a
plague yeah there's a kids play so the
what world we live in in a million years
but yeah if that happens I know it
sounds weird but I find it really
rocking and comforting that dissenters
are played no no so let's say the world
is ending right what it's like you you
get a text that says will dumping soon
but game over you like would you not be
terrified because well because nothing
matters anyway any like nothing matters
does it yeah would you not been trying
all those people that just had a newborn
kid well look beautiful baby girl love
it just go into the world very much just
like you shut your laptop all right well
I did my best but here we go short in
shortly index
yes maybe command space kill kill all up
all up effects traffic strip but if you
know market depends well because there's
no there's no one on the other side of
the tracks because they've died yeah
that's that seems the world has ended
everywhere except here and you're so
long let me tell you let me tell you one
of the examples I mean well in your
scenario a chris is saying the world's
gonna rent because of drones and plagues
but the Royal Exchange will still be
running until the world ends so yeah
those they can do that but you're gonna
you're gonna put a trade on so you're
gonna be dead just leapfrog Jeff Bezos
just cause well yeah you just see the
number of tirelessly nice alright yeah
and then die so let me tell me let me
tell you one of the things that robbery
even have I'll talk about on this so um
they talk about drones and they talk
about their ability to let's say that
everyone on the planet had a particular
pheromone signature genetic signature
that someone had been able to get hold
of they can plug this into a drum set
the drone away in this drunk and go kill
people so somewhere in the dark web
there's
particular forum where if you don't like
someone enough you can crowd fund a
software developer to set the drone away
on this particular piece of DNA then
crowdfunded together they meet this
particular level they immediately the
system just automatic automatically
sends an email to the target and says
you have 24 hours to double whatever it
is that we've met for this all this it's
coming after you
they then do it and the crowdfunding
begins again and they're now talking
like this extortion
all right for both sides a really
systematic skip this is a black mirror
episode yeah literally black mirror I've
never seen so there's the bees loads a
lot of these that respond to um when
there's enough tweet saying kill or
something like that so people hashtag
like kill this person and then when
enough people do it like whoever's on
the top of the leaderboard for that 24
hour period it sends out a bunch of like
lit microrobots which in look like wasps
hmm but they just embed themselves into
people's ears you can learn lately just
yeah this is because at this point in
the future in this episode or bees and
wasps are dead and they realized that
bees and what would be ease serve a
really important function so they just
create robotic bees that are events or
MN someone LP death but it's if you get
that email just go and covered just get
yourself under stairs covered forever
yeah well yeah well not forever like
they're gonna get bored and do you want
to someone else on visa no no the people
with the drone yeah I'm they got well
the problem of the beers that didn't get
bored and they were solar-powered yeah
is these net took less time so you need
to be in a dark space well they're like
they shot all the windows and made like
crap through your air vents and stoves
or horrible thoughts or just get a like
a globe like a fishbowl put it on your
head and seal it we need to air what
about if it goes our P Yuri through you
know bad [ __ ] yeah reverse kidney stone
you know just we hard we harder than its
push hard yeah oh yeah Mikey definite
constantly be we you know it's gonna be
difficult lot of air and water what have
you been watching you watched anything
recently no but
to remove things to the Marvel stuff yep
oh good I did see Punisher a while ago
which one daredevil the first series yes
okay I haven't seen that yeah very good
but then every extra Marvel thing I
tried to watch just the fuss is worse
like daredevil was okay oh [ __ ]
and then Jesse Jones was [ __ ] and then
watched like 10 minutes of the was it
like that
is it fist my interest and the big black
guy that he's hot his power is that he's
big Luke Cage yeah look that's that's
literally just I'm hard and black my
superpower is the one just might be one
really hard you know it very much felt
like the attempt at trying to make
something culturally appropriate yes
towards that side like here I think
Luke's headquarters is like in the back
of his barbers and it's like a very
traditional african-american Barbies and
you're like all right like it's great
but I mean there's other you know the
guys in the Avengers there's two black
guys in the Avengers and it's very
rarely referenced that they're actually
black mmm I'd love to see the numbers
like at what point does it become lost
making when they keep bringing them out
or are they just making some memories
really well it's they must at the front
chances to misses all over DC as well
teasers it's just like what's DC Batman
asleep alternative comic business
Spider Man Marvel yes yeah Superman DC
yeah that ever used to be under the same
no no because they do like crossovers
don't they
does he like Marvel vs. DC stuff I think
but it's the MDS not just pitching
Johnny you but you you watch it you
watch a fair bit Netflix I haven't
really wasn't like nothing that springs
to mind that's interesting the new our
planet with David am I'm not watch that
no pie half so yeah it's very nice like
evening what I think I think at the
moment because of my day is so like mmm
like I can't handle anything with a plot
anymore but just on a certain okay look
at trees and just yeah imagine what it's
like to not be realizing yeah
so one of my problems that I've got with
our planet is two orbits fun one of the
problems I've got with our planet is
that it's the entire nature program is
done under the guise of we're human we
[ __ ] the planet Earth so everything
every episode is just like layered with
this veneer of guilt you're hearing yeah
right like we the ice is receding faster
than the pace that a snail can move and
you're like right okay David like we
would you know the what the earth scan a
bit mr. David Arbor yeah I'm and it like
it's actually signed so many four
episodes in bits time to irritate me to
watch on mute it's just videos of the
world I want to hear like this is a this
is a crazy animal that like this is its
mating ritual and blah blah blah
I've got a mate who is one of the
cameraman all right oh you've told me
about that yeah did you not oh did you
not send me a steak did he do it for
planet Earth as well yeah this yeah
everything about is like it's incredibly
certainly States update so this guy shot
the scene if anyone remembers it from
Planet Earth
to where the Jaguar was walking through
the city okay Jaggi was going through
the city I'm not seeing that and he's
waiting
so there's once one shot in its a big
cast might not be Joker walking through
the city in the final episode and it's
pretty epic shot and it's like this long
shot as he's panning through and they've
been there for 13 days and this was the
14 tonight and it was the final night
that they were gonna be there for and on
the last night this next guy arrives
mean that's my overwhelming feeling when
I watch that show like the the guilt
scan it's like okay but share production
time yeah I've already sick and I'm sure
the md wants to be sick even more like
because the cost per second of filming
with those levels of cameras and I
imagine the hot like the hardware and
then I'm also like you're going to get a
swordfish that comes on might break one
of the lenses
and like you know I think shots okay you
think how do they get that from four
uncles in such high they're like how
long is quoted for ya
also the I imagine is if there must be
this when something's happening and
you're focusing on getting at you're
thinking like if I follow that forward
in the hope and reporting or like I
don't have to write how about you
imagine that it just must be disgusting
you're why he's off you trip over dead
David Attenborough's foot like while
you're tracking so you're planning a
Lily's the dolphins after after 13 days
of watching the dolphins have finally
arrived and as you're going along you
like trip over David Attenborough I'm
gonna burn are he's I'm gonna burn our
knees I'm gonna hit down does David go
to the places surely he's just in there
he's go some of them he does kill TV
disease you know these scenes of Cher's
knee yeah lot of nature did you see this
is really morbid and terrible but like
every time that someone famous and old
dies there's always a tweet which goes
viral which says what the [ __ ] is
happening hashtag someone get David
admin like check on him but it's just
like on safari somewhere is in the year
defending are imagine David Arbor is
like stabbed at Sunday morning is the
same as normal people but you know he
does I just imagine he's always like on
an expedition yeah fending off tropical
disease yeah he's probably - actually
David Sinclair needs to study David
Attenborough like and they're both
nights ones a night of Australian ones
and I've the UK and if David Sinclair
could work out what's keeping David
Attenborough live it is longevity
exaction I wrote some things down on my
phone for catch it
oh it was this morning before I did my
go warned nice
no we've got life hacks next we have got
life folks although life axel probably
did my face 5 kilometer run how was your
first 5 kilometer run really really
[ __ ] difficult ok you did front a
titty front but I can't do a thruster I
have not got the shoulder mobility to
get into a front rack position at the
bottom of a front squat that's years of
bench for you though
so I had to do back behind the neck
thruster I can't wait so we're doing for
the people are listening this will be in
the past now but me and Johnny are doing
his CrossFit on ramp tomorrow Johnny
thought that it was going to be someone
putting him in a pair of water wings and
a special helmet and say so this is how
you do a squat it's not rough what it
actually is is a two and a half hour
training session where there's some
movements demoed and then met cons that
use those movements interlaced in the
workout like the old metabolic sits down
visors thing no okay just whatever this
bloke fancies yeah and the guy that's
taking it won't be tremendously gentle
I'm there I'm afraid it's called Nathan
Nathan yeah yeah he's a big dude though
I think if it gets too much I'll just
attack Nathan I think do you think you
win either I think their word yeah and I
wouldn't back you I think if I'd grab
ahold of him and get him to the floor
I'll win but I think if it includes any
movement he'll win okay what else have
you done well so while I'm doing
crossfit mmm stop pause let us have a
moment of silence for Johnny's part oh
yeah
for now yeah well I just it's a series
of obstacles a series of injuries missed
entry for a competition without them
being any the the video for Johnny's
injury I have to like zoom in on this
but Johnny showed me a video from
squatting in the Doge garage yeah is is
quite physically Ping's he's a visible
invisible it's funny in the fiber and
the fiber Cena's it was
and yeah I I wonder whether look there
we're not if I have a squat weight like
that again at all getting my head I
think you're probably will well probably
but then as a you know again to fly the
flag for CrossFit if you know that you
can do 70% of that under extreme fatigue
from reps and wraps and wraps I bet that
you won't be worried hmm I am I'm
interested about CrossFit but huh I
think I'll either love it or hate it I
don't think the LMS is a middle ground I
don't think there is I'm worried there's
gonna be too much cardio for me to enjoy
it we had a chat about this and it was
saying that powerlifting kind of
optimizes for one really specific thing
which is fun in the process but then
when you get to like the 99th percentile
and you're just flipping between 99
that's a 9.5 it's really really
unpleasant and very little gain whereas
doing something like CrossFit even if it
is a bit cardio biased you just feel
like an athlete again you just feel like
you're actually so what's the biggest
thing for me is that I've stopped
enjoying training and like usually being
something that I love doing like was the
favorite my favorite part of the day and
at the moment the thought of training is
like so for the perfect example of this
I've been injured pretty badly injured
now for seven or eight months and I'm
still going into the gym to do a special
needs version of CrossFit because I want
to train because I look forward to going
in and getting after it mmm
but yeah it's it's a different sort of
because you did I remember the CRISPR
episode that we doing on our podcast
where you were eating me from body
building over to my excitement I was
still doing it to novios yeah so we'll
see what else been happening I went to
see aunt Middleton is that the guy that
does it with deck no have you seen is he
the one in rehab no that's it I want in
rehab no so it's not an attack okay
right aunt Middleton is the presenter
one of the presenters on - therapy No
yes this is like the table Goggins
UNICEF drug his favors no it's um he's
he presents the SAS are you tough enough
right thing former Special Forces guy so
bloke the one-to-one no he's he's quite
famous now right he did a talk at the
City Hall back he got me tickets for
Christmas yep called mind of a muscle
now both of you would have found it
intensely difficult to sit through
because it was very it was like I've got
put it you have a positive mindset go
look at situation and just think how can
I think positively about a mask or
something saying but there are a few
things he said that are really
interesting principally it this clips
where he climbed Everest and you can
just see glimpses of like what it takes
to be in the SAS so like there are
people coming down Everest so you that
you met me go like base camp come one
back down again
base camp come one come two come one
down again and do it that way why to
gradually acclimatize the altitude he
was like did base camp camp one saw that
there was a dangerous bit risky bit
whether it be no avalanches I [ __ ] that
I don't know do that multiple times
I'll just go base camp camp one bat down
the end and I'll just go to summit
everyone's I can't make time [ __ ] how
the [ __ ] was gonna come on kid on me he
had miss right and he's going up and
there's a storm storm warning and was
like we need to amazing no it's okay
fuzzy months I never spoke of it
like this you see a camera here here's
our militant and then you see this okay
you get an appreciation for that just
how steep it is I know that's obvious
but like real estate really still yeah
and they're really experienced crimes
come down they're like you need to meet
roosters I [ __ ] tell your bankers
rope restaurant what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you and then so he gets to the
summit and there's a hairy bit where
like there's a shelf called Hillary's
shelf I think and a guy in front of him
slips and is about to fall off the
mountain and people are getting blown
off and dying in front of him and this
blokes about to be cut off
for the mountain by the Sherpas and he's
like I'm gonna die he's up there for
eight hours in the Death Zone gradually
die the death the death so it's past a
certain altitude there's not enough
oxygen so you just dying slowly oh it's
a race against not he's like considering
just jumping off
and at the very event she reaches the
bottom when he's like that sicko she's
not ever before is gonna die and the
shipper just tense at Middleton News
goes you're crazy a positive this is a
man who's living is to go up and down
Mount Everest looks at that middle
finished goods you're crazy
[ __ ] Julian did is it is it like
an Ironman run where it's if we did it
in Libya and it's like it's in the
desert and you have to run for 36 hours
it's like it's like it's like it was a
hundred kilometers and it's an
ultramarathon yeah and he he didn't have
his insulin and so by the time he got to
like 30 kilometers a muscle names like I
really need mine see they're not haven't
got it and they've managed to get this
doctor to come over Fonda like and they
had an ambulance that has five-year
expired insulin Libyan insulin and he
was just and he was like well this will
have to do but he said there was one and
they kept stopping they had like
backpacks with pans and food and stuff
so there was this one guy he said just
look like Skeletor from the beginning
like didn't have any backpack just had
like two gels and just started running
and just that was it I didn't take any
breaks didn't sleep just just kept
running for the whole thing and his time
was just vastly different to the next
person dark there's a good a good
documentary about Courtney to walk the
current ultramarathon record holder
right and it's her doing a trail run for
250 miles I want to say vailable on
YouTube brand-new one and it takes her
50 hours without without sleep I flew
back from New York yesterday and did 23
hours on a plane without sleep it's not
ethical still pretty difficult but I was
reading my book mm-hm
reading me book being sleep-deprived
such a weird feeling it's the same as
diet like the it's so forefront of
everything so visceral like when you
need food all you can think about yeah
when you miss leo yeah yeah what am I
gonna get to sleep when we're gonna be
alright I have my things which I think
if you're hungry you can kind of forget
about it whereas if you tie it will not
leave depleted so yeah yeah the hunger
thing like that what's the longest
someone's ever gone without he sings
like 370 days or something but it was a
guy who was with a big yeah he was
pretty big to begin with and you
thinking like he had he was supervised
he had minerals and vitamins and fluid
and enough calories on him yeah okay
thousands of calories just to put more
back underneath did Italy really that's
[ __ ] heartbreaking
wow that is Harper no more [ __ ] fast
for a year so you gain it back again
it's um the example is used in Johann
Hari 's lost connections right and he's
talking about the link between
environment and waken adore environment
I'm about to have it so suppose many
machines that [ __ ] about no machines
not to blame what have we got coming up
what's gonna be happening soon so we've
got how to survive after university when
you've discussed that that needs to have
a cap because otherwise well it's gonna
go on literally forever as rest of my
cattle yeah how have we completed
relationships yes so relationships is
done we might come back to I guess for
some reason I can't get
stop explore you had some really good
ones I've got their runs of titles I
forgot what they were they're all
against drama by Johnny how it gets
strong that's gonna happen what else is
happening Johnny there it is podcast
topics truth about working for yourself
self-discipline and habits truth and
honesty is a superpower help survive
University strength training or how to
survive a night out and notes on human
behavior from night clubs which is going
on in for that one I've also helped in
terms of guests that I've got coming up
Thiago Forte from for taillamps yes
which should be a big one Thiago didn't
respond to my tweet yesterday
he's busy guys I'm also gonna start him
on the practice yeah yeah
very clever dude what are you to him
saying saying hello I offered him three
months of coaching in exchange for Conan
remember all right didn't you pay for
one of his products and save a [ __ ] I
didn't didn't someone else Jordan might
have what did you pay for in Sobers [ __ ]
big bundle oh yeah his his was the only
bit there was a different thing in it
but the rest of the bundle was
horrendous awful yeah I'm also going to
start doing uh I'm organized with a few
different DJs and club owners from big
clubs so Pepe who was the founder and
owner of space of ether is coming up
Pepe yeah him and some of his marketing
team and we're going to do tales from
the dancefloor which is going to be like
epic stories of like party legends so
that'll be happening Christoph also
known as cozy is gonna come on he's
gonna talk about some stuff I'm gonna
try and get Erik Prince when he's over
it's very lean Christophe joke from
jacked out of his mind I used to train
in David Ward Newcastle used to do a lot
of incline bench reports
well it looks incline bench fires bench
press loves why is his name Chris CJ
Costigan but he's yeah plays him to kid
Christa very deep voice freely in
Yahoo's I'm one up yeah yeah I believe
you've met him in a sauna the other day
because I was with this guy who knew him
nose ring and then I come over if he had
a nose ring yeah but he would is that
quite tall big forearms yeah Jack very
vascular for ya and little naughty
trials that I used to get yeah good guy
but that's it is there anything else we
don't don't be it W ok by Derek Fox oh
is it
what life ax it might be life hacks
might be I've got another life Fox
that's all my palace last week though
they've broken the rule of podcast land
anyway if you enjoyed the episode please
comment below fire us any questions do
not forget to subscribe and follow apps
propane fitness on Twitter and all of
the social media
okay bye Dan hey bye Joe
[Music]
you